taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two foods gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
them
hey taste buddies it's a taste buds
podcast
i'm uh joe i am a nego montoya
you killed my father prepare to die we
uh
listen we just started recording because
we're we're roughly four hours behind
right now right whatever we're supposed
to start today about 2 p.m yeah yeah
uh it's going on about seven
uh i'm kidding it's only five we're
supposed to start at four is it five
oh babe it's after five oh it's 5 11.
yeah dude wow
[Music]
it hurts shut up 311. hurts when you
feel like it you know you told me he did
an interview with 311 recently and they
were like shitty
i i did doug getting doug with high with
with the the main not the guy's got the
weird nickname it's like butterscotch or
something or anyway he was pretty nice
oh from 311 i don't know i don't know
who i don't know them i don't know their
names
there's one with a nickname okay peanut
butter or something okay yeah something
like that
but anyway yeah
today's episode another summer well sort
of half summer battle today we put today
is big there's a lot of weight behind
today it's the quintessential
fourth of july barbecue cookout
versus the
[Music]
quintessential thanksgiving dinner yeah
and let's say right now cookout meaning
cook like we didn't want to call it
barbecue because some people call it
just cooking out a barbecue
but we didn't want you guys to think
we're regulating it to uh uh relegating
it regulating it relegating relegating
it to like literal barbecue like you
know hot dogs you know cookout food yeah
you you have a scope of barbecue foods
but it is all pretty much this is
cookout steeped in bbq
there's there's this is cookout food
well cook out means barbecue
well barbecue means barbecue well
where are you out cooking
first of all if you're from the south
what we do on the fourth is called
grilling that's not even they don't even
they won't even call it a barbecue okay
okay he's got to be in a smoker okay so
that's what you mean you mean
all the fanfare
and what's the spread i'm having a party
what am i serving for the fourth right
which can let's just touch on what that
could be
burgers
chicken ribs stink brisket yeah
cornbread yeah uh uh it's sour uh uh
what am i thinking it's the sauerkraut
what's the thing i'm talking about
the shredded cabbage coleslaw it's the
most diverse
meal next to the thanksgiving meal the
thanksgiving meal you got your turkey
and then you got sides out the wazoo and
then your pies yeah yeah excuse me oh
you're you're including
the pies
i'll let you include those in the
thanksgiving meal well you just gave
something away there but oh [ __ ] your
boy here will be taking thanksgiving
meal and i'm going with uh
cookout food uh on the fourth of july
uh
because once again
sal has somehow decided he had to defend
what will probably be the clear-cut
winner that's not what
i'm on like a five-episode losing streak
i know i'm just kidding
and you came to me with this matchup and
i said i'll true it
i'll do it but i gotta i i could only
defend thanksgiving here no i know i
like you you could defend the come on
you couldn't defend the cookout i i run
the burgers episode where you said
staple babe every grill next to the pool
don't act like you didn't say those
things i know but i i against
thanksgiving i can't besmirch
thanksgiving like that i mean it's a
fantastic meal thanksgiving yeah it's a
fantastic meal uh pimp can you look up
the fan that brought this to us it's in
the link you sent us it was right
towards the top it was one of the only
or not one of the only but it was one of
the first uh
fan suggestions
that we got back in the youtube poll
uh
they off uh i just want to say the
person's name i kind of feel bad that we
keep like thanking people for things and
not saying their name
all right we got there it is right there
right at the top david owen thank you
for the suggestion
all right dave yeah we're doing your
thing babe
well that's an interesting one too he
also suggested best or worst vegetable
that's interesting because we did that
with fruit
best or well worst vegetable let me
think
best i've gotta go
sweet potato if that's a vegetable
maybe spinach sweet potato as your best
vegetable spinach you're a bad [ __ ] what
am i forgetting hold on leave it alone
maybe we revisit this
[Laughter]
leave it alone all right anyway listen
sweet potatoes certainly the most
nutritious
let's come back to it don't waste the
gold don't burn the gold we were arguing
before we got on the show today
speaking of summertime and events and
things parties oh i had a big party
saturday or sunday you and pimp were
there for the old b day yes and then
people going online going what's up with
nobody mentioning derosa's birthday on
the episode today it's like bro we're
not
it was taped a week ago yeah
although we recorded chris
the one that's going to be chrissy's
chrissy's birthday is on a hey babe day
at thursday and and so we said happy
birthday because we knew it was airing
that day so he will have what you failed
to achieve
but your birthday wasn't on a monday it
wasn't on a monday you're right it
wasn't everybody thought it was on that
sunday or something i don't know well
that's the day you threw the party yeah
the point is we had a big party on
sunday yeah the egg party great yes
started at 6 00 p.m
i went home about 3 00 a.m
uh
i saw many pictures of myself oh yeah i
could show you i can pull up photos
right now but you will see that you are
dead behind the eyes yeah
you have no soul
you know we want to know i'll show you a
picture right now and i'll show you too
it's a picture of you looking at me yet
there's no way you know that i'm
standing right what was i talking to you
about i remember having my arm around
you for a long time i feel like it was a
very sentimental discussion but like my
god man i was right you were alive man
people were just buying you drinks yeah
it's my favorite thing in the
world you know
that you're looking at me
i'm telling you don't you don't know
i'm telling you another bit please
send up the pip send all the birthday
pics to pimp
please
you got to put these up but yeah there's
brutal brutal there's a video where i'm
talking to you in the background of paul
italia
proprietor of the stand dancing into the
camera
and i'm talking to you dude and i look
like i'm gonna like fall over yeah
there's a picture of me and jay it's
just i always feel bad because when
we're out i'm always like you need to
hydrate yeah what is it yelling about
him about hydration
but it was your birthday you were
supposed this is allowed this is a meant
to be yeah my shorty birthday yeah sure
so shorty yeah i also dj'd
you don't even remember that
right you know brother
for like two hours did you go back to
bed i say dj i chose the song say what
else i didn't remember that you came to
the stand with us
what
i remember standing in patties and going
what happened to sal where'd sao go and
thinking my memory of that being at the
first part of the night at this at the
at paddy's at paddy's yeah and then
i saw these pictures of us at the stand
together i was like
south carolina oh yeah then you had like
an hour's long blackout we went i was at
the stand for three hours we went back
to paddy's after that what no yes no
you're an animal that late it was the
wee hours what time was it i left at
like after midnight
okay yeah not a lot of we lost a lot of
good men on the way to patties not a lot
of people made it
you remember that though wait you
remember going back to paddy's but not
that i was flashes of it but we but you
just said we had a you saw the full
conversation we had at
i saw a video of us talking in the
background of paul dancing i can't hear
anything
i was
with
and or in your orbit or around you
for hours straight i've had
easily easily five to eight
conversations with you i have a faint
memory of having my arm around i was
standing in front of you djing while you
danced
we had a long conversation i was
videotaping you singing along to music
i mean i got some disturbing pictures on
my phone here dude i'll get these to uh
i'll get these over to pimpy
look at these things we got to when we
got we got to uh the stand
and then uh
seth
turned to me and he was like that one
yeah that is deserving i don't know who
that is but i have you here
look at that one
yeah yeah yeah look this is you this is
the reverse angle of that
oh that's great
lost every gift he gave me almost every
gift wait here's oh yeah
i lost every one of the gifts he bought
me the once upon a time in hollywood
book
that's a friend of mine luisa she's very
nice okay she took good care of me yeah
yeah okay she's a good care of me uh
this is
this is paul dancing into the camera
that one actually i can't send that one
to pimp there's us talking in the
background
yes there's sherrod kissing me on the
face yes i i was i was i remember every
moment
how i don't understand well i probably
drank like
900 less than you
you know i had i had i had some drinks
but i was waiting
at the next place
i didn't he put it up
oh oh did you just you sent all these
now i just sent them like four or five
okay send them on the picks
i remember the moment the night where
deroza came to me he goes yeah i
switched to beer from liquor and that
was early on because you said you were
not feeling good
i wasn't feeling bad yet i just couldn't
i was like if i keep up with this
uh it's over i will die if i keep
drinking
like tequila like this oh that's a good
one
well you can't just sit here and scroll
to your goddamn phone
i'm sending these to pimp
i'm sending these to pimp so we can put
them up on the screen
the uh
all right anyway
but that's not the argument we had the
argument we had and we gotta we gotta
move into the debate soon but we we what
babe i'm just fixing a badge it's you
gotta stop with that let's just push it
in why it's so weird
it's so weird you have a thing dude it's
the corners of the pillow are supposed
to be out
why do you work it's not going to work
for me why do you push it in it's not
going to work for me i have ocd bro you
want to get into this now can we just
argue why only one corner
you don't know you don't know this the
only question i know he's got ocd but
why one chord look at that it's the only
corner pointing at me
jesus christ dude
just a disaster who is the dude taking
pictures of everyone that nobody knew no
idea
so there's a guy right he's like oh
that's my friend crystal's friend
your friend
crystal my friend chris was a friend of
mine from l.a where was she she was
there
all right no i don't know i didn't know
the guy he's taking photos
all night long he takes pictures i
thought he was hired by the stand to
take photos
here i am posing he's i'm having i'm
having conversations the guy coming in
my face taking photos while i'm having
conversations i was like oh i guess the
stand is just doing that thing where
they document the night or whatever like
how we have like you do and stuff and
then
a little while later he took some more
and then i said to him i said to you i
go oh your friend i said who is that
that keeps taking the pictures and you
said to me i have no idea who that
person is
i don't really know and i said wait
the guy who's at your party that is
photographing you and us and everyone
here all night long incessantly i didn't
know he was you know
who that is i go i thought he was your
invite he goes no so then someone goes
don't worry sherrod knows him i go to go
you don't remember any of this yeah you
don't remember it either i do remember
now that you're saying it i go up to
straw to go hey uh paul told me that
this is your friend here he goes never
met that guy before in my life
i said so who is he here with you
because i have no idea i go to paul i go
paul do you know who he is he goes no
but joe and sherrod and i'm like no they
don't he goes they don't i go no he goes
i go you don't know me because now i go
so who is he he goes i don't know
and this guy was photographing us for
hours i watched that it was bizarre yeah
now
i'm just curious real quick and then we
can move on what state was i in when you
were speaking to me at this point
you were not there
you were not there you i i do they look
like they look like you you somebody
popped in two fake eyes in your in your
sockets
there was nothing there was no soul
behind your eyeballs it's not much there
when i'm sober yeah
i know
you were doing that thing where you had
like a little bit of a smirk on and you
were swaying and looking through
everybody
like this was like if i was if if you
were me and you're my point of view and
i'll be joe
[Laughter]
i love it
i love it i love it
why is drinking so fun
anyway
um
but that's not what we i said at the top
of the show we got a little bit of an
argument not an argument debate not
about the party
about something else summer related
uh we have friends going down to a house
that we rented in long island
and i asked you if you'd like to come
join us you said yes
we're going from friday to monday
you want to do
two spots on friday night
at your home club
that would totally understand that that
you can get a spot at any time you're
there
seven days a week in the afternoon
selling sandwiches and seven nights a
week doing spots already the owners are
you some of your closest friends there's
no obligation to do it whatsoever
not that long ago you declared that you
quit stand up and won't even be doing it
anymore and now you're
holding you're making yourself beholden
to two spots late on friday night and
you want to come to the beach house
after that so you want to leave for the
beach by 10 11 p.m and get there three
to four hours later and come at two in
the morning to join a party already in
progress because you want to do the two
spots here's my thing instead of just
canceling the spots and getting arriving
at 3 p.m in the afternoon and getting
nine more hours of a pool a fire pit and
a barbecue in with your friends it won't
be nine more hours
if you arrive at three instead of one in
the morning that's exactly nine hours
so here's the thing sorry it's 10 hours
here's the thing
you
you know what the first date a beach
house is like
nothing happens you're unpacking the
stuff whose room are you taking no no no
no no no you're not gonna you're not
gonna reverse tell me that you're a
misprioritization of this event by the
way you're not coming over
two of the key players can't get there
until at least 10 11 o'clock at night
there's only seven people total yeah the
other people will be deplete two that's
that's a big loss that's the key players
you're only there till monday
yeah it's three nights yeah well it's
not a beach has to be out for the summer
it's just for the week yeah so there's
no unpacking i'm gonna get there and
just get go get we're gonna hit the
ground running i've now been on two
trips with you
i don't know
yeah we've been on more trips than that
yeah two house rental trips i don't know
if you're aware of how you pack
you showed up the first time we went
away
with a full computer in separate bags i
mean i don't mean a laptop i mean a pc
so he could plug that was for vr just vr
let me paint this picture a little bit
it was april 2020 it was the height of
the pandem
and it was the first time we were going
away we were taking blood tests just to
do it we were going away for like
actually we rented the house for two
weeks although i was only staying for a
week but i bought the virtual reality
it's connected to a computer bay like a
pc so i brought by the way jay and i
brought oculus quests which don't plug
into anything
yet he thought he should bring a full
desktop i was doing i put the labor in
for the benefit of the group
didn't didn't hook it up i'm just saying
the labors appreciate it but let's not
make make it sound like you're hopping
out of your car onto a boogie board
sliding into the pool that's what i'm
doing this time
that's what i'm doing so you think
i'm going to do what i did
a year and a half ago at the height of
the pandemic and bring the computer away
you did it at the
last time we went to this very place no
i didn't you didn't bring the computer
but man you brought stuff yeah but i'm
sorry how does this you should see pimp
space right now it's the same as all the
listeners right how does this affect at
all that you should come down and get to
the pool in the barbecue in the grill
i'm saying first night at a beach house
is usually the slow night you unpack
things joe if we're gonna
today's gonna be a very heated episode
if you keep watching right am i wrong i
can't argue with someone who's being
purposefully irrational i'm not being
i'm not being your friend you're making
a case for staying in manhattan and
doing two 12-minute spots at your home
club that you're there seven days a week
for no reason oh you got new materials
to try out i do
damn it
you're also talking to me like i got
weight to throw around this business i
don't it's the stand you already told me
i've got very limited weight by the way
i'm only there three days a week doing
sandwiches stop emailing me everybody
and saying why is your sandwich shop not
open it is three days a week wednesday
to friday 12 to four it's called a
pop-up a pop-up isn't open all the time
that's why it's called a pop-up
so when is it open wednesday to friday
12-4 that's it that's how a pop-up works
wow
i didn't know either but also it's just
funny that you're mad at potential
customers that are trying to support you
no but people
emailing us because people who don't
want to answer your emails about how you
can buy this product i'll answer the
emails but you know what else you could
do you could maybe look at the posts
that have all the hours listed what if
you go on the website sandwich
daddy
it's not asked with love
it's like bro you gotta open your shop
once in a while dude every time i come
it's not open it's like no you don't
look at the hours and you come when it's
closed let me assume this if you're
getting that many requests for it to be
open when it's not maybe you maybe
expand the hours and the days what do
you think i'm doing
opening the shop that we've i've been
talking to you about you think that's
just for shits and gigs oh you're on
edge today boy
you are on edge today
you're yelling at
how dare you nobody yelled at you for
attending the party and nobody yelled at
you quite frankly for the request to
come down early
you cannot make the case that you should
be doing a spot on friday night i don't
want to get to the pc there you i know
so stop with the whole song and dance
why do you have to do the song and dance
you know you're probably going to be
there you know
just like darth vader
told luke you know in your heart of
hearts what you are okay come on what
the hell does that mean
i'm saying
you you i feel like i don't gotta
convince you because in your heart of
hearts you know that coming down at
three o'clock we're allowed to check in
is the right move and getting 10 extra
hours of relaxation with your friends in
and that whole time you know how much
damage you could do at a fire pit a
barbecue and a pool in 10 hours you're
gonna stroll into two and one you're not
gonna be tired by the way you're gonna
do 2 10 p.m spots then drive three hours
and then you're gonna get there and
we're gonna have been there drinking and
eating all day and then what you're
gonna just go to bed
no
well but
i don't understand what are you gonna do
when you roll up at one in the morning
maybe take some time for myself
[Music]
get in there when we're allowed to get
in there i understand i understand i
understand i understand in
a year from now in six months or now a
year for now and five years now 10 years
from now 20 years from now are you gonna
remember the trip in montauk or are you
gonna remember the spot that you did
friday never know it depends what
happens at those spots maybe it's gonna
get discovered yeah do a spot in montana
spot yeah surf lounge go ahead here's
what you do here's what you do you want
to try a new material come at 3 o'clock
i'll get in the pool i'll get you a
little you'll stand up and i'll look up
and you do this you do the material to
me and i'll give you i'll give you on
i'll give you honest i'll give you
honest feedback better yet not even do
the material right now
i will give you honest feedback right
now and then you could call out of the
spots go ahead uh i'm not doing the
material you got to do the material for
me right now i'm not doing the material
it's a must what's the premise
just just give me just just give me uh
just dance give me a little material
uh did you ever go to jeremy go to the
beach house with your friends what is
the big deal about that first day
this is the bit
this is gonna buddy you should just come
to the beach
everybody makes such a big deal about
this first day we gotta get there
why do we gotta get there
supposed to be relaxing you're already
stressing me out
[Laughter]
i didn't write fake seinfeld bits for a
year straight for nothing people folks
some stuff is just better to do at home
i know for me one of those things
probably top of the list is exercising i
don't want to go to a gym and people
watch me i want to do it in the dark at
home well i cried exactly i don't want
to have to leave the house either i want
exercise to be as convenient as possible
and guess what the good people at
peloton are making that even more
possible than it ever has been before
okay i love the fact that you jump onto
this thing you pedal away you look at a
video screen you're listening to music
it gets you motivated you can join fit
motivational classes and groups and and
connect with friends
right there's the screen on the front
and you could do customized workouts you
could go do workouts with friends you
could pick your own personal instructors
there's there's artists collaborations
instructor curated playlists uh i i it's
just they just make it fun you could be
at home alone but it totally feels as
communal as possible and it's a total
body workout experience which i love i
love a one-stop shop so whatever your
mood or overall fitness goal is
you're gonna hit it here you can mix and
match classes you can choose cardio
strength yoga pilates outdoor arousal
all that jazz you know peloton you
definitely heard about it and all i
heard about friends that have it they
always talk about it and i'm jealous and
i heard about over the pandemic you
almost couldn't get one because that's
how in demand they were right
now i heard it's a little bit easier to
get one and now i'm so thrilled that
they are
a sponsor for us here's the thing i've
jumped on at a friend's house i do not
have a peloton on my own and i say this
to peloton right now if you're listening
and we know that you are
uh please send us some pelotons and help
us transform our lives i will be your
your voice i will be your mouthpiece i
will get on my peloton and i will relay
my experiences my daily experiences
because i've always worked on a friend's
bike i also have used to friends and
it's it's very very important and i
didn't have the special shoes but this
is my device yeah i mean but also too by
the way
he was telling me this when you get the
bike you just get access to live classes
like that and thousands of like
on-demand things and
it's just i don't know man it just seems
like they've made this as easy as
humanly possible so i want one of these
bikes with the peloton bike there's
nothing like working out from home learn
more at onepeloton.com
new members can try the peloton classes
for free for 30 days come on guys at one
peloton dot com app okay that's o n e p
e l
o t o n dot com
babe babe i got a case of vizzie's uh in
the mail and i they're in my fridge
right now and i cracked one open
yesterday and i got to tell you this uh
heart seltzers are abound these days
and
there's a lot to choose from but i
really really liked the visi mango
watermelon kicked my socks off
okay
it has antioxidants and vitamin c if i'm
going to cell sir by the way less than a
gram of sugar a hundred calories that's
my favorite part tastes delish but if
i'm gonna have spiked hard seltzer i
also like why not have the one that has
vitamin c and antioxidants i'll tell you
this they say that wine has healthy
traits to it and i'm drinking a little
wine right now and i gotta tell you what
i miss the vitamin c
the antiox
and the less than one gram of carbs of
sugar
yeah i think you might be getting
antioxidants with the wine i'm not sure
they say but how do i know but they have
printing it right on the can no wine i
ever had had it printed on the bottle i
love watermelon they're their flavors
are all watermelon blueberry watermelon
is knocking my socks yeah there's mango
blueberry kiwi passion fruit um my
favorite is is mango
it's it's a hundred calories like we
said and uh what are you gonna do i mean
upgrade the your hard sell sir to visit
that's the whole point of this that's
what i did to find out where you can
purchase vizzy go to vizi which is vizzy
vizzyhardseltzer.com
tastebuds that's
busyheartselter.comtastebuds
to get updates on the latest flavors and
more sign up for the emails at
vizzeehardselser.com
subscribe that's
subscribe you need to be 21 years old
yes
all right well you do what you want uh
i'm probably gonna go to your show
you don't understand
you live on this puffy cloud way up in
famous person land we're all not living
on that cloud you come in
you talk you come into the club you say
put me on they say
when sir that's not true i go i abide by
all the club laws i go in i say why is
the show late they say go
so
not true
you don't have to paint this picture of
me baby
i don't do that at all
if anything i'm like oh thank you so
much i know you're very nice and you're
very you're very grateful i'm not saying
you're not i don't go in and throw
around demands i don't go in and bump
anyway i don't do that i'm not even that
first telling you you walk this was when
i knew where i stood in this business i
saw michael che come in for his show the
other night
i have never seen friends of 15 years at
this point the way they acted when he
walked into this club that he we
the way who my friends by all my friends
at that club that i work at i didn't see
shay it was you you weren't there oh
okay that's why you didn't see them
because you weren't there but no not not
for the party the club for a show
he came in 15 years exaggeration 10
years though
friends i have known since that club has
opened my home i'm there all the time i
he walked in
he sat down the met the gm is coming
over
can we get you a drink what do you need
what club is this the stan oh the gym
your friend and i start that's what i
said i started making fun of him i go
you
mother
have never done this for any of us look
at this how you fall over yourselves
cause a credit just walked through the
door
uh
so that's that and he was very nice and
very grateful and he was very very
accommodating but i'm just saying
it's a different world for a guy like
what does that have to do
with the montauk house and you're not
doing dudes
this is the way he does taste buds it's
the way he is in real life canceling
it's brutal
it's every time with everything cancel
in spots
you do not apply logic you are fast and
loose with logic i i've always had i've
always had a bad self-image i've always
been very hard on myself and that feeds
into this stuff so excuse me
i'm not projecting anything
what is where i stand the way you stand
in the business because i don't have a
good self image i think that if i if i
don't do everything that people will
boot me out of the business that's how
my mind works okay i think that
everybody around me is better than me
what about the fact that you're invited
to the beach house oh mr famous throws
out the beach invite now we all gonna
drop what we're doing no i'm kidding i'm
jump joking i mean though
no one knows
you know no one knows that
that no one knows the semantics of the
beach house i'm just saying there's a
bunch of comics at the beach house
you're part of it i know i believe that
all of you are better than me you're
just going to have to accept this about
right leave me alone
we're all begging you to come early i
turned 44 i had a birthday party i knew
a third of the invitees do you
understand where my head is do you
understand what i'm doing to try to feel
something do you get it yet
which i would i would mean you would go
to my no i still don't get it
but i would think going up and relaxing
with your friends
at the beach will help
will help
mitigate your your horrors you'd think a
lot of things about me but you wouldn't
know
look i'll probably cancel and come we're
you know we're having fun
if you do that would make me most happy
and we know that's where you're headed
and that's why my point is why do you
make us have these
just come up to the house
post taste
yeah i probably will
i probably will he can't commit
i can't commit right now he probably
he's probably going to pull today for
five minutes because he wasn't sure if
it was worded properly
i'm a perfectionist come on what do you
want to do
all right speaking of which we got to
get into
the debate i mean you're gonna here's
one where i'm feeling pretty good
finally i've been on a slide uh as most
of the listeners and viewers know
and uh you're going up against what i
think is
a hallmark
granted let's acknowledge the fact cause
i said this to you when you when you
propose these two yes
these are
uh
traditionally united states based meals
right i mean thanksgiving dinner and
fourth of july
down to even down to even not sharing
them even with canada and mexico they
are they are fully united states-based
holiday meals now i think
it's not like we're referencing
something they don't know about i i
think they're known around the world
still because they're they're
commercially very big holidays and
there's all kinds of cartoons and movies
and whatever devoted to both of them
thanksgiving more so than fourth well
maybe not but um the thing is this too i
think a lot of
countries have equivalents to this
to these holidays okay in other words
like
you know they'll be like christopher
columbus went over there and and did
nothing wrong to anyone over there
either yeah well or you'll say you'll
say you know what is this day here and
it's oh the day we celebrate our
independence or whatever you know no it
might be with different food or whatever
but wow i'm going to get cream today
why are you saying that holidays most
commonly celebrated thanksgiving is
number two fourth of july isn't even in
the top four
i'm gonna get creamed
no no no then the picture not
necessarily i mean we're just talking
about the cuisine of each day so let's
talk let's talk cuisine we're not saying
what's the better holiday let's talk
cuisine
i love thanksgiving i love i love your
sides that you bring to the table i love
i love cookouts the thing i love about
thanksgiving sides the most all of them
contain uh in either creamy or moist
quality to them
so you can really get a beautiful mix
going on the plate you know that
cranberry is going into this into the
mashed potato mashed potato into the
green bean cass green bee cast with the
stuffing the gravy's finding its way all
around that plate yeah so i can't argue
any of that i can't argue anything it's
wonderful but when it comes to main
course
i've got you beat by a landslide because
turkey that's all you got all you got in
main course is turkey and that turkey
oh you better do it right oh you better
do it right a juicy succulent turkey i
always say i'll tell you why i think
thanksgiving
i've heard this conversation 100 times
in my life people say why do we only
have thanksgiving dinner on thanksgiving
of course and a lot of restaurants will
do a little take on thanksgiving dinner
i've had a thanksgiving dinner on a
sandwich um
i certainly practice
i i mean stuffing i think stuffing is
going to cremate everybody it's going to
scorch earth every single side and
stuffing is one of the greatest things
ever made ever
and i wish i could have stuffing every
day of my life now stopping you
you know what myself why you know what
it's unclear at this point
it's it's a very unhealthy dish
unfortunately yeah but how about once a
month maybe i'd love it
you're not doing a stuffing we do
stuffing more than every thanksgiving
houseboat
um you're not doing a stuffing once a
month
no but i really would love to babe i'm
doing a stovetop maybe every two months
stovetop is different i grew up with
that but i'm running i'm running with it
for a few days after that yeah you put
it in put in the tupperware you put it
in the fridge and then eating the cold
you heat it up every time it depends you
gotta throw a little water in there
maybe get it get it uh depends it
re-eats okay yeah it doesn't reheat
poorly here's the thing i i'd say i
don't necessarily disagree that you have
with cookout you end up covering a
larger scope of proteins and main
component meal based foods like your
ribs your brisket your chicken you get
you got you you do have all that in
cookout so i wouldn't count fourth of
july cookout out because you have a
breath of way more options well you got
when you when you look at the main dish
at a cookout hot dogs
burgers cheeseburgers
chicken grilled or barbecued it's almost
unfair bill this is almost like ribs
hot wings i i run into a lot of yeah
it's almost unfair because you you have
such a scope of foods that i'm going up
against some people it's grilled foods
some people are breaking out shish
kebabs some people are putting some
lobsters tails on on uh
that's bad
for tails i think i'll leave fish i'll
leave fish out yeah but let's take me as
far as shish kebabs and we're at about
seven protein dishes here and the sides
at a cookout are no slouch either
they're not only
the only competitor would cook outside
sides for a meal is thanksgiving because
that cookout you got
no i won't say they beat thanksgiving
and sides but i will say they they bring
something to the table and they're the
only holiday bringing that much to the
table outside of thanksgiving they got
potato salad macaroni salad coleslaw
regular salad
uh
definitely baked potatoes on the grill
we got baked potato at the thanksgiving
there's a little bit of crossover you do
a bigger
thanksgiving
well mashed
cheese at a cookout
cheese at thanksgiving i i mean look
turkey beautiful succulent dark meat
white meat you know fried not fried it's
not the star of the show for me this the
star is the sides but you're getting
that sweet potato you're getting mashed
potatoes and gravy you're getting corn
on the cob you're getting all sorts of
greens um
really any which way you slice it you're
getting sweet potato but you're getting
it with sometimes with the marshmallow
and the syrup which is a delectable
treat you get the cranberry sauce but
the stuff that's the least favorite side
of all time cranberry sauce no i love
cranberry sauce no the sweet potato
marshmallow thing i hate it oh i don't
love marshmallows in it but the sweet
potato at thanksgiving and the stuffing
are the things i'm real and plus i love
corn on what corn we share but here's
the thing
i think it's because the cookout food is
not exclusively fourth of july where i
just was making the point that i always
long for thanksgiving dinner more than
just on thanksgiving and it rarely
happens
that's not the case with the fourth of
july cookout and so i don't think people
are going to be so closely attached to
that because they have it more times in
the scope of a year when thanksgiving
approaches i'm not just getting all warm
and fuzzy inside because i'm gonna see
my family and friends and have a little
time off and the the leaves are changing
and it's ushering in like it's
mid-holiday season and you know all the
good things that come with thanksgiving
it's a sensory experience as well and
then you look forward to that meal i
immediately becomes the cornerstone of
the whole thing it brings all of those
things together the family the friends
the time off the football the weather
yeah it's beautiful it's all symbolized
by the meal it's beautiful and i start
to look forward ahead of time and what
i'll do a lot of times i'll split that
thanksgiving day in between family and
then usually even the day after or the
day before i'm catching maybe someone so
i'm having like two or three different
thanksgiving i go i go hard at
thanksgiving plus the leftovers i go fam
all day yeah
that friday and wednesday night all bets
are off i'm i'm i'm clocking it in with
some friends i'm having yeah yeah here
you're just getting you're just getting
social laughs and then you're sleeping
and then you you're curing that with you
all day long the first go-round then
you're going up for seconds and then the
leftover game at thanksgiving cannot be
matched bbq doesn't really keep well as
leftovers
burgers dogs hold on i disagree i
disagree i love a leftover grilled hot
dog i agree with the burgers burgers
don't keep i love a leftover grilled hot
dog
what are you reheating it
sometimes they go cold i love a leftover
hot dog like with the char on it and
everything i love it but here's the
thing i don't know if that's a
you're in the minority i like it but
here's the thing dude i agree with you
on the burgers
cold ribs or reheated ribs are always
awesome cold chicken
a staple reheated chicken a staple your
sides
from fourth of july are going to keep
way better because they're served
chicken you don't love cold i love cold
chicken no dude you could you could get
you could you could i don't know if i
love reheated ribs either i love i love
cold leftovers i don't contest that
cookout leftovers
is a tough sell oh dude italian sausage
on the grill i forgot about that
uh you're talking a veggie tray with dip
dips come on dude you can run the gamut
on dips on fourth of july dude onion dip
spinach artichoke i would be careful not
to uh water down your argument here i'm
not i think that's water i don't think
you should be expanding to crudite
that's not crudite a vegetable platter
that's crudite it's a definition of
crude it is yeah raw vegetable platter
that's what it's called yes sir really
what about a bat what about a bowl of
ruffles with a french onion dip you tell
me you're not putting that out at every
fourth of july cookout i know i am all
right well then allow me to introduce
pies into the mix go for it allow me to
introduce pies thanksgiving pies go for
it delicious pumpkin pies
apple pie all the pies yeah i see
i
vanilla i see your pie you know what i
made it with rocket pops
ice cream cones yeah there's something
about that thanksgiving pies though
that's dense
rich memorable material right there well
look you're not gonna know these people
are making all sorts of
people are going to people's houses
bringing potlucks bringing trays of all
sorts of other treats nobody's gonna
argue is the lord smorgasbord nobody's
gonna argue that a nice pie
is not a higher grade dessert
than a rocket pop however you want to
talk about once a year hot fourth of
july day you can't wait to get that
rocket pop in because again it's sensory
it's so special it's like this thing
that you never ever ever get to do
cold beer outside on that fourth with
the barbecue food
fuse well i know i got trounced right
now but a beautiful glass of wine with
my thanksgiving dinner you're drinking
wine with that see i don't think juan
goes for thanksgiving dinner i think
it's too many different if you're
looking for a ready lineup of
binge-worthy podcasts plus free
streaming music you have to check out
amazon music yes has more than 10
million free podcast episodes but it's
not just for listening to podcasts they
have thousands of different music
stations to stream for
free no matter what you're listening to
you can even go hands-free with alexa
get the app enjoy listening anywhere on
all your devices there's no credit card
there's not even a subscription required
i started using it i use it at the gym
on when i go downstairs i use it in my
car uh it's it's kind of like
i just throw it on i play a station and
it curates it for me i like to put it on
and not think yeah i always find myself
on my other apps like the song's up and
then i gotta need to find
i'm a huge music fan and just being in
entertainment like i try to subscribe to
all the entertainment apps that i can
and amazon music is really impressive
with how intuitive it is for your tastes
and what you like and what you want to
hear so if you've never tried amazon
music what are you waiting for you're
gonna love it as much as we do start
listening for free
today go to amazon.com taste buds that's
amazon.com taste buds you're gonna
stream thousands of music stations and
over 10 million podcast episodes for
free free is the big thing free
amazon.com taste buds
joey's in the bathroom right now i'm
going to start this candid thing without
him okay joe's in the bathroom right now
and i want to tell you a little bit
about candid let's see how he reacts
when he comes out there's a specialist
for just about everything right when my
car breaks i go to the mechanic when my
shower breaks i go to my plumber so when
you want to get your uneven crooked
teeth fixed you see an orthodontist they
are the specialists and that's what sets
candid the invisible comfortable and
removable aligners above the rest while
poorly reviewed oh hi joe while poorly
reviewed or insanely priced clear
aligner companies use general dentists
candid only works with orthodontist joe
let me tell you a little bit more about
candid i've been telling our listeners
with case i heard you in the other room
talking about candid yeah and i thought
i want to get in on this yeah and then
you
like to human beings that would like to
fix their teeth but candid the same
orthodontist who created a plan is with
you from start to finish so you never
have to wonder how you're doing your
treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an expert in tooth
movement and am i seeing here that the
average candid treatment is just six
months
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs thousands less than
traditional braces
with i mean that's the problem so many
people can't get these stuff done
because they can't afford it they don't
have the right insurance whatever it is
it's nice the candidate is offering the
service you can uh get apparently
straighter and a brighter smile that
you've always wanted and you can also
save 75 dollars i don't believe my eyes
and you're not going to believe your
teeth
when you get the candid starter kit and
you get started from home or you can
book an appointment at a candid studio
near you today
go to
candidco dot com slash taste buds and
use code taste buds that's candid c o
dot com slash taste buds with the code
taste buds take advantage of this
limited time offer to save seventy five
dollars on your starter kit candidco.com
taste buds code
taste buds
it's too many different how about some
beautiful hot apple cider my friend let
me not even get can i get into apple
cider can i get into fresh baked breads
can i get into a fresh lemon can i get
into some strudel can i get into a
freshly squeezed lemonade can i get into
a sun tea
a sweet tea a sun tea yeah that's tea
that you put the tea bags in a jar and
of the water and you leave it and let it
like become tea with the sunshine in the
sun yes
basically sweet tea oh okay delicious
but i mean you know
look here's the thing
i mean just
beautiful spiked hard cider we got made
heated up in a pot but we got off we got
off we got off the one thing that i've
seen
so important
turkey does not keep well you know it
doesn't it dries out so quickly it is so
hard to cook a turkey properly and get
it juicy and right you you know that
that's hard and i would also say this
well i mean you're talking about
grilling 10 different proteins with
different rules easy stuff easy stuff
you can't you can't we're arguing the
better cuisine the better holiday meal
you can't you don't want to bring in the
fact that turkey
is difficult to make
a turkey will you hold thanksgiving if
it's not done right you know it will
yeah it smells like you know uh a lot of
fires on thanksgiving from people that
try to deep fry turkeys yeah one of the
biggest calls on things here the fire i
have a lot of friends of the firemen
yeah they got a lot of calls those days
without ever hear fires from fireworks
fourth of july yeah okay dude
they they are two two holidays they get
the fire department called there's
fireworks for fourth of july is the
busiest day for the photos yeah like
hands down the busiest days if you
listen you will hear sirens 24 7. i
didn't say it wasn't i just said i never
heard of it oh you're insane well i'm
just saying i've never heard of it so my
truth can be my truth you know what
i could argue to you that although it's
hard to grill a steak it is hard oh
getting a temperature right now what
you're doing
babe i'm watching gordon ramsay most of
my day
okay i understand how hot it is to grill
steak even though i don't know how to
grill one
it's not usb recovery steaks and roast
be cooked to 145 degrees and then rested
for at least three minutes yeah to
ensure food safety grumpy yeah but you
know listen look i'll tell you this you
know there that that turkey i love i
love that leftovers i think thanksgiving
leftovers which is a big part of the
celebration too i just you don't there's
not even a thing called cook out left
but you know that's that's what are you
what are you doing you're just throwing
some you're throwing some you're
throwing some red beans it's you're
throwing some red franks and beans in a
in a tupperware you're breaking
uh
cookouts and barbeques when you're
thinking about your leftovers you
probably shouldn't save anything that's
been sitting out for more than two hours
okay
it's anti leftover the cookout it's not
anti-leftover you just put you cook what
you need and you put it right but you
wrap up dogs and burgers and have them
the next day they will never ever come
close to what they should try to eat
white meat turkey the next day it's
drier than wood i know but i put a
little i put a little i put it in the
microwave gravy all right i put it in
the microwave with a little ketchup or
mustard i mean what are we talking about
here anything can moisten up meat yeah i
mean you're gonna i mean enough
just a huge a huge chicken leg the next
day i'll do barbecue chicken the next
day is awesome oh i don't like it it
tastes too gamey you're you're nuts
that's crazy getting just pork
fried chicken
what are you doing what do you mean what
kind of food you eat next day cold over
everything's fried chicken everything's
gonna be tough you're gonna
i don't know dude i don't know what do
you mean i would leave it out
your leftovers suck
they don't the sides from fourth of july
hold up better than i never hear anybody
being like you guys want barbecue
leftovers from yesterday everyone just
like let's just barbecue again i do it
all the time in fact you my friend
have sent me home from this very
apartment
with bags of barbecue leftovers that i
eat for days maybe chicken breast
burgers too
salad i mean look i'm just getting done
as opposed to throwing them out i'm
trying to be a gracious host and send
you home and i eat them and they're
delicious that's fine i'm just saying i
don't think the way that thanksgiving
leftovers are something that people talk
about and and look forward to i never
hear that equivalent to barbecue
leftovers look i i agree with you thank
you people more than not say throw it
all out
here's the thing 30 gallon garbage bag
and they say throw it out and then they
barbecue again the next day there's a
point for that there's a reason for it
trying to tell me you're going to eat a
kebab there's a reason two days later
there's a reason
two days there's a reason you're kebab
on july 6th there's a
there's a acaba all july you won't kebab
you have no idea not not with leftover
kebab i'm telling you something there's
a reason for all this there's a simple
explanation for all this thanksgiving
dinner is a gigantic pain in the ass
everything takes forever a turkey
sucks to cook it's it's hard to make
it's heavy it can be dangerous we've
established okay
every side is a pain in the ass to make
if you're making real stuffing it takes
time it's a pain if you're making real
green bean casserole it's a pain it
takes time and i like to cook but these
things take time so when you're making
the argument that anything delicious
that takes efforts
no that's not what i'm saying so when
you put all these dishes together all of
them
taking this much time
you're goddamn right the leftovers are
going to be an event because this was a
pain in the ass and now we don't want it
to go to waste barbecue you can manage
what you need way better it's way easier
to determine what people want how much
you're going to use and whatever and at
the end of the day you sell out 250
worth of potato salad you're not going
christ almighty i slaved over this all
morning
but that's what people are doing on
thanksgiving people are offended at
thanksgiving if you serve box stuffing
or frozen green bean casserole or store
bought
to the argument i'm saying it applies to
the argument because you've got a
built-in default leftover tradition
based on the fact that people are
slaving over this meal it's still the
tradition still exists i still have
leftovers versus not really leftovers i
would say i would be i would dare to say
with a barbecue there aren't many
leftovers and when they are when there
are it's a negligible cost and if you
like it great and if you don't it's it's
no big it's no big loss anyway
listen this is a funny uh go to the
phones for one sec for this show
according to my girlfriend this is on
twitter fourth of july cookouts consist
of the easiest meal drunk people can
come up with and thanksgiving is the
ultimate food holiday it has something
for every family member very good point
this is a good point here's the thing
here's the thing i don't think and i'm
hoping because i have been taking a bath
lately but i don't think that people
will also be able to disassociate
the warmness
and
appreciation of the holiday with the
food i feel they're connected in their
dna and so i feel that when people think
about thanksgiving they naturally will
attach i'm curious
to their families and the holidays as a
whole to that meal and i think that that
will makes the meal uh tastes better
it's an intangible that doesn't
necessarily exist at the cookout i'm
curious we need to go to the phones
anyway because it's that time okay and
i'm curious to see because i think both
these holidays create a lot of
excitement for people i think they're
both little mini holidays in the sense
that you get a couple days off for work
maybe maybe one
uh you have it and it's over before you
know it but it's an excuse to get
together with friends eat like a pig and
drink your face off i think that's the
there's a lot of uh symmetry between
these you all right you're all right
there is a lot and uh
i don't know pimp i i know that you you
have eyes on the thing as it goes
and sometimes i look at you and i try to
read your face
and i i can never tell because even if
you have like the face you have on right
now is a knowing like a knowing smirk
and that means i believe that someone's
dominating but i can't tell who it's
gonna be i have a feeling it's gonna be
thanksgiving thanksgiving's part of your
big three i mean halloween thanksgiving
christmas that's your big three
yeah but outside of of the holiday
season
ain't cane nobody be fourth of july and
that was dramatically correct i agree
i'd put fourth of july over new year's
eve
so do i i don't like new year's eve i
like new year's eve a lot i don't like
it it depresses me well because it's the
end of the uh it's the end of the time
and it's good i don't need to be
constantly reminded that we're ushering
in
new people all right let's read these
thanksgiving is like a warm hug from a
person you love fourth of july is like a
hug from a sweaty uncle who talks too
much
ah yes thanksgiving where the whole
family argues over politics and judges
all your life choices why would wouldn't
i pick things well hold on we're not
talking about the conversation i know
they're just going to have an influence
on people
4th of july people are just out in the
streets lighting off lighting off
explosives smoking marijuana everybody
voted for the same guy on fourth of july
it's america it's all about america
that is true it's just everyone's just
getting shit-faced drunk on the floor
but people are also doing that to
medicate against their family yeah
that's true i think fourth of july
cookouts are so hyped
like it's about partying et cetera and
the true meaning is lost as the years
pass by oh for christ's sakes i don't
like that
that's an opinion with heart
there's nothing more traumatic than the
fruit sauce white people make for
thanksgiving
ain't [ __ ] great
grateful about that that's our contender
fruit sauce
morgan i think it means like the canned
cranberry sauce but that morgan is in
the lead
wait that's not
morgan celebrate thanksgiving
basically you're asking if i'm wanting a
nap or to party all day bbq is always
dope but q i but but like you i love a
turkey leg and then could use a nap yeah
that is a good point too it puts you to
sleep man come on man you you posted up
on that lazy boy you're watching some
football you're watching a halftime show
get to that ladies no are you maybe not
if you can get to that lazy boy because
everybody wants that one the people that
i enjoy every thanksgiving for falling
asleep after dinner my whole family
makes fun of me
and i'm like what do you guys want from
me the people that enjoy their families
are gonna love thanksgiving the people
that that have heart attack anxiety
going home for thanksgiving or going to
their home are gonna hate it morgan with
two cookouts are pure americana you
can't beat that with a dry fat bird and
cranberry sauce as much as you can
morgan is going in heavy on the fourth
fourth of july style cookout always
smacks thanksgiving dinner is good day
of day of and the day after that's it
that makes zero sense thanksgiving for
sure because the fourth grandpa thinks
i'm grandma and gets touchy
fourth of july is only good for that day
too my man if you choose to cook out
over family time and the huge spread you
are nuts
the non-american audience is mostly with
thanksgiving there's got to be a like 80
20 or 10.90 win
all right thanksgiving's the one holiday
where it's accepted and even expected
for you to eat like a goblin 10 out of
10.
10 out of 10 would choose thanksgiving
turkey come to wake up and coma to wake
up oh come on sorry
i guess thanks tiffany's family the
other morning the fourth of july cookout
i'll tell you another thing in
thanksgiving is that i didn't even even
begin to touch on when we're attaching
mood to it
i mean
it's it's black friday that i mean the
christmas season gets kicked into hyper
drive the night this is my favorite time
of year i know but and thanksgiving is
like i know thanksgiving is like the
door guy at the christmas night club you
see him you have a nice little exchange
and as soon as you pass him it's i'll
forget it it's a christmas party stuck
it to me good today by insisting on
thanksgiving you didn't even touch on
like the freedom of our country and and
we're not here really to talk about the
holiday we're talking about but you do
attach emotion i think so the me like i
said i think it's the better version of
of uh fourth of july of uh uh uh new
year's eve jesus god i i agree with big
mike here uh fourth of july equals super
hot baseball games flies all over your
food and annoying neighbors who pop in
way too much and use way too many
fireworks thanksgiving entire day of
football numerous family recipes cooler
weather where you could be outside not
sweat your bowls off gotta have a ham
guys bringing ham into the mix
illegal
no no no no no legal first people took a
handstake on thanksgiving
absolutely listen i know the elasticity
of that all right here we go let's see
what we want pimp let's get more let's
give morgan the win that white people
fruit sauce was very funny
we gotta wrap this
morgan wins give morgan a follow it's at
m-o-r-g-n-d-o-e-s-n-t-c-a-r-e morgan
doesn't care
all right we're naming it white people
fruit sauce now
i'm actually nervous
uh 10 000 votes okay refresh this
10 000 seems light how did it go down
300 votes just now
how did that even happen uh ten thousand
twelve it was just a little hiccup okay
thank you lord
bless us oh lord these i guess which
you're about to receive from thy bounty
to christ our lord amen i just said
grace babe because i'm so thankful for
this win i finally
am on a winning side again it's been a
while uh i was really feeling like i was
in a funk there
um
i am on tour right now going throughout
i'm going to be in a city near you uh
it's with the guys we're touring it's an
arena tour the tenderloins.com tour for
tickets that are on sale right now if
you don't see your city cities will be
added look for
savolcanocomedy.com for all my solo tour
dates there are a bunch out there now
but i'm announcing all of 2022 soon but
check it out all the time i love you joe
and i will be cancelling you
and i will be canceling my only two
spots
coming up because the guy with the arena
tour is insisting
that i get to a beach house five hours
earlier
on time yeah on time uh jonah wrote a
comment on instagram and twitter joey
rose's is coming real soon guys uh it's
happening really the the actual brick
and mortar joey roses is coming very i'm
very excited to bring the information
about that that's gonna be fun i'm gonna
i'm gonna probably bartend one night
yeah we're gonna have guest bartenders
it's gonna be nuts guys trust me i'm
gonna do a big big announcement on the
show when it's when it's ready to blow
up or open excuse me uh
uh that's it thanks for subscribing
thanks for listening spread the word
yeah thank you if you follow us please
rate us on itunes or sp
and uh spread the word it really really
really does help i still love you babe
love you
the
too
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste bud